obviously we have to get to the horrific
story that happened yesterday
i'm sure you know what happened already
but
an 18 year old gunman opened fire
yesterday at a texas elementary school
he killed
at le last time i checked it was 19
children it may be more now and i
believe two adults as well finally the
attacker was killed by law enforcement
the hideousness the horror of the crime
speaks for itself
my only hot take on this
i don't have a hot take
that's my hot take my hot take is i
don't have a hot take my hot take is
the reflexive political posturing
that that happened
within minutes of this news breaking
is so
revolting
that i just refused to engage in it
and it and it plays out in the
predictable way that happens every time
there is a shooting event if the shooter
is
white it's all about white supremacy if
the shooter is not white as in this case
it's all about gun control and you have
all the usual suspects immediately
rehearsing their same points their same
either sincere or more frequently
feigned outrage about the lack of gun
control policies in this country they
never propose anything in particular
because none of the policies that they
have proposed would have stopped any of
these shootings
historically speaking obviously more
facts will come out about this one but
that's been the case in all of the other
ones and then they they become very
indignant and self-righteous and they
say how dare you offer thoughts and
prayers how dare you suggest that we
take a moment and pray because of this
horrible tragedy and they they
themselves don't offer anything else
and then maybe some of them the more
radical of them will say
well we just need to get rid of the
second amendment if that's the
impediment we need to get rid of the
second amendment and even if one were to
think that that was a good idea i don't
think that's a good idea but even if one
were to think that's a good idea
it's not practicable at all it would
start a civil war so they're not they're
not offering any solutions they're just
they're just jumping up and down
on
at the at the very moment of a tragedy
of a really unthinkable tragedy
to push their same old tired political
agenda and you'll see it a little bit to
conservatives then will become very very
uh reflexively defensive and they'll
look in and say well was this guy an
illegal alien or was parents illegal
aliens or was it an illegal gun and
they'll they'll try to get all of the
facts to score their political points
too obviously in much less so in a much
more defensive posture than you're
seeing from the left but the whole thing
is just so sickening it's so
absolutely repulsive
that i would just suggest
you don't need to take you don't need to
take
you don't you don't
and everyone talks about thoughts and
prayers
and and on the left they dismiss
thoughts and prayers they themselves
offer their own thoughts immediately
they never stop offering their own
thoughts or whatever whatever even
resembles a thought to them
no prayer is just just
i would i would recommend just just
prayer prayer is pretty good it's the
most efficacious thing that anyone is
suggesting
it is the
it is the
classy thing to do it is the civilized
thing to do
you don't need to jump the very second
that an a really unthinkable haunting
tragedy occurs you don't need to jump
that very second to push your political
agenda or frankly even to push back
against someone else's political agenda
or to find all the statistics or to find
all the right facts and to say boom c
owned debunked got it you don't have to
it is so
classless
it is so
inhuman
it is so uncivilized
bad things can just happen
and you can just
feel sad about that and you can just
pray
because none of your none of your
posturing
you know
you might observe that none of none of
the posturing the proposals that come
out would have stopped this may that can
be debated later on what is certain is
none of your posturing is going to bring
the dead kids back it's not going to do
that
the only thing you can do is pray
that could even possibly have any effect
so maybe just do that maybe that's fine
it's so
i i almost can't look at twitter right
now
i almost can't look because
and it's not it is being driven by the
left it's not it's not only the left but
it obviously is being being driven by
the left and it's so
crass and vulgar and so
disgusting
just don't have to do it
this is common sense this would have
been considered common sense common
courtesy common class
not that long ago
but we've lost all sense of that all
sense of decorum
maybe people weren't raised right maybe
they just don't get raised right anymore
i guess that ties into the education
issue people aren't really raised right
have some class have some manners have
some common sense i'm so glad you liked
that clip now hold up stop ring the bell
ding dong like subscribe whatever you
got to do get the notifications for the
michael knowles show head on over to
apple podcast spotify stitch or google
play wherever you get your audio
podcasts subscribe over there leave a 25
star review we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you